[Música]
la justicia rusa prohibió la actividad
de la multinacional estadounidense meta
platforms de ofrecer las redes sociales
facebook e instagram en el territorio de
la federación rusa por considerar que la
compañía promueve las actividades
extremistas sin embargo esta decisión no
aplica para el servicio de mensajería de
whatsapp de meta debido a que no
contiene funciones para la difusión
pública de información así lo dijeron
las autoridades rusas mehta anunció días
atrás que era forma temporal por la
ofensiva militar en ucrania permitía a
los usuarios saltarse sus normas de uso
y enviar los mensajes que normalmente
estarían prohibidos en un comunicado el
portavoz de la compañía explicó que las
excepciones se permiten con carácter
temporal por la operación rusa en
ucrania si no incluyen amenazas de
muerte creíbles contra civiles rusos sin
embargo me estás y permite el
llamamiento a la muerte del presidente
ruso vladimir putin y su homólogo
bielorruso alexandr lukashenko emitidos
desde ucrania polonia y la propia rusia
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado del día el es
wilson vega periodista especializado en
tecnología ex editor de redes sociales y
actual director del portal especializado
abecedario punto gracias a wilson por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 porque esta decisión porque me
está tomó la decisión si finalmente está
violando uno de sus principios de no
incitar al audio
raúl muchas gracias pues es una
situación inédita y muy a menudo en este
campo de la tecnología nos encontramos
en zonas en donde nunca habíamos estado
y en esta particular meta tuvo que
decidir cómo iba a manejar la
publicación de mensajes que como usted
anota son en rigor violentos y llaman a
la violencia pero están en el contexto
de algo que occidente reconoce como una
invasión de un estado soberano
si bien esto es lo que abre la puerta a
las sanciones habla también de cómo las
empresas necesitan tomar una posición y
en este caso la posición que toma
facebook que es la de al menos
temporalmente no vamos a cortar estos
que son llamados a la defensa un estado
legítimo ahora uy son evidentemente son
compañías y cuidan por supuesto de sus
intereses como toda la compañía que al
finalidad tiene meta con esta decisión
de permitir mensajes de odio contra
rusos obviamente en el contexto de la
guerra es correcto en este caso entonces
hablar de la rusofobia denunciada por el
gobierno ruso por el kremlin
yo creo que no si bien es posible verlo
así facebook ha sido menta ha sido muy
muy clara en decir que por ejemplo no
permitiría el llamamiento a la agresión
no digamos al asesinato de civiles rusos
o de rusos en general
por el contrario creo que hace más en
ese sentido la prohibición de que
personas que no están involucradas en
las acciones violentas en rusia utilicen
la red y yo creo que sí existió pero
bueno como el que usted identifica pero
la acción de facebook de permitir estos
mensajes creo que se parece más a la de
poner etiquetas que contextualizan
ciertas informaciones cuestionables en
otros campos como el de la información
de sobre kobe y me parece muy eficiente
que lo que está ocurriendo en rusia sea
una prohibición de facebook y de
instagram pero no afecte a whatsapp al
aduciendo que whatsapp no es un medio de
información cuando pues por supuesto
puede serlo yo lo que veo aquí es a un
gobierno como el de moscú restringiendo
el acceso libre a la información estaría
meta entonces violando alguna ley y
teniendo en cuenta también eso que
solamente se bloqueó
instagram
y facebook digamos y no whatsapp siendo
de la misma compañía y siendo la misma
compañía declara extremista
yo no lo veo así pero también falta ver
cómo evoluciona es decir para saber
cuánto tiempo sostiene meta su posición
actual y falta falta a ver si las
sanciones rusas se extienden como pares
de que se podrían extender a otras
empresas como google y particularmente a
su servicio de vídeo youtube pero la
noción de utilizar palabras como
extremistas o terroristas para referirse
a las principales plataformas y a las
redes sociales más conocidas del mundo
hablan de un paso más en este tema del
control del discurso que parece ser es
cada vez más importante paramos claro
digamos entonces que esta catalogación
de una organización extremista como como
meta simplemente fue una excusa para
bloquear estas plataformas en el
territorio ruso
pues digamos es una forma válida de
analizar el tema yo creo que sí yo creo
que en la decisión de meta hay una
posibilidad de una puerta que se abre
para que el kremlin tome esta decisión y
de nuevo me parece preocupante ver cómo
va a evolucionar porque el el regulador
ruso de las telecomunicaciones y un
nombre que no voy a ni siquiera intentar
pronunciar este te ha dado a entender
que estaría dispuesto a llevar la
legislación en aplicaciones prácticas y
las aplicaciones prácticas de una ley
contra el extremismo que contemplan 15
años de cárcel y es lo que tiene a
opositores rusos en problemas con la
justicia entonces es una forma más de
escalar el conflicto lo que pasa es que
cuando usted está tirando misiles sobre
hospitales y son las residenciales pues
bloquear lo peor que usted está haciendo
pero si es una cosa preocupante en el
contexto de la libertad de expresión
global claro y sobre todo como usted lo
decía en oposición porque la posición
por supuesto usa todo este tipo de
mensajerías alternativas por toda la
censura que hay
prensa rusa para enviar sus mensajes sus
convocatorias de manifestaciones una
oposición cada vez más acorralada como
afectaría esto a la oposición dentro de
rusia
sí señor hay implicaciones directas
porque ya no estamos hablando
simplemente de
señalar cuestionar castigar no estás
hablando del bloqueo del bloqueo
efectivo de dos aplicaciones muy
importantes y puede que eso para los
influencers sea un problema económico
grande pero para los opositores como
dice usted pues es perder una plataforma
grande para sacar el mensaje al mundo
dicho eso no es la única forma y en
estos momentos las las redes virtuales
privadas vpn se están volviendo
absolutamente esenciales para quienes
están tratando de todavía utilizar
internet de una manera anónima y no tan
restringida en territorio ruso
publicar mensajes contra el conflicto se
está volviendo en rusia cada vez más
peligroso porque solo uso de palabras
como guerra o como invasión calificaría
para ser sujeto de esta ley de la que
estamos hablando entonces la oposición
pues tiene que andar con cuidado algo
que es prácticamente su estatus y
recurrir a cosas como las vpn para poder
seguir sacando el mensaje wilson ya
rápidamente pareciera que me estuviera
leyendo las ideas pero quería hablar
precisamente de los simples de rusos que
obviamente ganaban dinero con sus
publicaciones y con toda la publicidad
que les pasaban las marcas en sus
cuentas qué va a pasar con esto porque
además con las sanciones económicas
muchísimas tiendas y muchísimos
muchísimas empresas que pautaban estas
en estas cuentas en estas cuentas se
retiraron de los entonces qué va a pasar
con ellos rápidamente
pero es complicado porque hay gente que
tiene realmente su estilo de vida
asociado al uso de redes como instagram
y por supuesto eso habla también de las
ganancias que dejan de tener o sea
personas que tienen cien mil
cuatrocientos mil dos millones de
seguidores estaban sacando un sustento
de eso ese sustento les cae a 0 de la
noche a la mañana y pues este yo no sé
que tanto tenga que ver esto en el
contexto la de la guerra pero habla un
poco de como éstas ya no son actividades
tangenciales o vis no hay gente que vio
alterado su estilo de vida y su tráfico
de gente de recursos pues sí por el
hecho de que meta tenga que dejar de
funcionar su trabajo prácticamente
porque al final es un trabajo un trabajo
digamos diferente a los tradicionales
pero bueno wilson gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de frança 24 para hablar sobre
lo que está ocurriendo en ese ámbito
también en la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania gracias wilson gracias a ustedes